-I can't believe
it's already the end
of the third season of the show.
-I know. I know.
I can't keep up anymore.
It's crazy.
-It's -- It's flying by.
-It's going so fast.
-And -- And one of the things
that is a -- a change is
I feel like Randall and Beth
were laid out
as this sort of perfect couple
over the first couple seasons,
and -- and this season,
we sort of explore that --
that maybe that's not the case.
-Right.
-Yeah. Has it been --
[ Laughter ]
Has it been -- I mean,
it's weird to say, like,
is it fun, as an actor,
to take on that change?
Because, of course,
it's a more, you know,
negative energy to be playing.
-Right.
-But do you enjoy it?
-Yeah, negative is always fun
because it's, like,
it's challenging.
-Sure.
-Right?
And then, it's a total change-up
from what we have been.
But I kind of feel like
it's realistic, right?
It's life.
I think,
if they stay too perfect,
people would start
to question that,
or people would say, like,
you know,
that's not a representation
of a real marriage,
and we want to do our best
to really represent
what people go through.
So, I found this struggle
to be really challenging,
but, you know, I'm doing it
with Sterling K. Brown.
That's not bad with him.
-Yeah, it's not
that challenging. Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-You know, it's...
-One thing you had to do
without Sterling
is your character had to rely
on your background.
You have a dance background,
to some degree.
-Yeah, yeah.
-'Cause there was
some dancing for you this year.
-There was some dancing.
-Did you have to go back to
the -- to the drawing board?
Did you have to retrain at all
for this?
-Yeah.
They wanted me to do ballet,
and, like, I left ballet behind,
like, maybe when I was like 14.
-Yeah.
-Because I didn't like it,
but when...
[ Laughter ]
-Good reason. Yeah.
-Yeah, that was my thing.
I mean, Misty Copeland kills it,
but, like, I --
but, then,
I went back to train for ballet,
and I found out
I still didn't like it.
-Wow.
[ Laughter ]
-And so, I was like, "Okay.
What we gonna do now?"
'Cause they wanna do ballet,
and I was thinking...
So I asked them.
I said,
"Maybe modern dance, y'all.
Does she do African dance?
You know,
I can get down with that."
And they were like,
"No, it has to be ballet."
So I was like, "All right."
Then I got this
brilliant choreographer,
Nia Brantly, who started
teaching me and coaching me,
and she's fantastic.
And she made it feel like
it fit my body,
'cause I'd always sort of
been told, like, you know,
"Your stomach sticks out,
and your butt's too big" --
all these things that
I didn't kind of fit
into that genre of dance,
and then she made it feel like
I could wear it on my body
and -- and do it
sort of boldly and proudly.
So, it worked out.
-Yeah.
-I feel like, you know...
-It really did work out.
-Yeah, it worked out.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I'm glad you -- you guys
put the work in together.
-Yeah. We put a lot of work in.
Yes.
-You -- this show, obviously --
I don't need to tell you --
has -- the fans
are very passionate about it.
-Mm-hmm.
-You --
Are your family members --
are they --
would you would you put them in
the category of passionate fans?
-[ Chuckling ] Yes.
[ Laughter ]
-Oh. Is it good or bad?
-No, it's -- it's -- it's good.
-Yeah.
-Um, no.
I have, like,
this whole text chain.
My family in Jamaica's
gonna love this
because they're --
they're on this text chain,
and so every time the text,
you know, comes out,
they have commentary
about the show.
And so, you get different things
'cause, you know,
people are kind of divided with,
you know, there's
a lot going about --
about Team Beth or Team Randall,
and, you know, so...
-Some people in you family
are not Team Beth?
-Oh, yeah.
-Wow.
-No, my...
[ Laughter ]
...my family keeps it 150, okay?
It's not...
[ Laughter ]
So -- So, you know, sometimes,
you know, they'll say --
you know -- you know,
"Randall too spoiled.
Him too spoiled.
You spoil him too much."
You know what I mean?
And it's like...
[ Laughter ]
You know, or --
or my niece will say,
"Um, Auntie Sue, can you
explain to me what your --
how you feel about the
Team Randall/Team Beth thing?
Because I'm very Team Randall,
and I was wondering
what your point of view
would be,
just as a normal person
and not an actress,
about what..."
[ Laughter ]
"If you were just looking at it
objectively, like,
who would you..."
[ Laughter ]
And I was like --
I went to back to --
I was like,
"So, you're team who?"
She was like, "Randall."
[ Laughter ]
And -- But I get it.
I think it's fun.
-Yeah.
-And I mean...
-And that is a better option
than them not watching the show.
-At all.
-Yeah, absolutely.
-So, I mean --
that means they're tuning in,
and I'm -- I'm definitely
Team, you know, R&B
and, you know, hope for the best
for the -- for the couple.
Absolutely.
-There you go.
-So, yeah.
-And this is very exciting.
You shot -- is it
"Won't You Be My Neighbor?"
the Tom Hanks film?
-It is called now "A Beautiful
Day in the Neighborhood."
-"A Beautiful Day
in the Neighborhood."
And this is the
"Mister Rogers" movie?
-Absolutely.
-Shot in Pittsburgh? Yes?
-Shot fully in Pittsburgh
except we did a couple days
in New York.
-Oh, cool.
-Mm-hmm.
-And was that -- that must have
been a fantastic experience.
-It was amazing
because I was sandwiched
between Sir Tom Hanks and
Chris Cooper and Matthew Reese,
and so I couldn't ask
for a better cast
for my first feature film.
Yeah.
-Well, that's exciting.
-Mm-hmm.
-We can't wait to see that.
-Yeah.
-And congratulations
on another season.
Give it up for
Susan Kelechi Watson,
everybody.
[ Cheers and applause ]